vividly the moment when we launched the
European green deal exactly four years
ago back then clean hydrogen was the
dream of a few
Visionaries many of whom are in the
audience
today those Visionaries believed that
clean hydrogen could be Central to our
transition towards climate
neutrality with its potential to power
heavy Industries to propel trucks and
trains and to store seasonal
energy today four years later the
hydrogen economy is blooming the first
Hydrogen buses are running in European
cities from Ria to
Barcelona construction Works have just
begun on the port of rdam to build a
hydrogen Network that will span for over
1,000
kilometers and weeks ago the world's
first plane powered by liquid hydrogen
Cruis the Skies of
Slovenia it is the dawn of the clean
hydrogen
era and all of this is happening thanks
to people like you pioneers and
Believers in the clean hydrogen
revolution in these four years we have
done our utmost to support and accompany
you to help you bring innovative
hydrogen solutions from the laboratory
to the factory from the factory to the
market and from Niche to
scale we've been working on three main
strands first strong public investment
to scale up the hydrogen Market second
International cooporation to build a
global market for
hydrogen and third a new partnership
with the private sector to Spur
innovation so let me update you on the
progress we have achieved so far on each
strand of
work first on
investment the European green deal is
backed by Massive
investment with Next Generation you and
repower EU we are investing in hydrogen
valleys hydrogen trains and clean steel
factories we have authorized over 17
billion euros in state
for roughly 80 hydrogen projects across
the European Union and this week we're
taking the next step launching the first
auction of the European hydrogen Bank it
is backed by 800 million EUR in European
funding and more
importantly it will attract private
sector financing and result in
commercial off-take
agreements today I can also announce the
next steps for the European hydrogen
Bank in Spring
2024 we will launch the second round of
auctions reaching a total value of3
billion
e it is a promise we made one year ago
and it is now becoming
reality in parallel we're also working
on the international lck of the European
hydrogen Bank
this will secure Diversified Imports of
renewable hydrogen from reliable
suppliers
abroad and this lead me to my second
point that is developing a global market
for clean
hydrogen we have already signed hydrogen
Partnerships with countries ranging from
Egypt Kenya and Namibia to Latin
American countries they have immense
potential to produce clean energy
transform it into clean hydrogen and
then ship it to the
world and here at the hydrogen week new
and I must say exciting initiatives will
see the light and will be discussed with
Kazakhstan Australia and
Oman and together with President Lula of
Brazil we are announcing the European
Union's support to build one of the
biggest hydrogen projects in the world
in the Brazilian state of
pwi it is part of a 2 billion Euro
global gateway
investment in the hydrogen value value
chain in
Brazil this new green energy Park will
be a 10 gwatt production facility for
clean hydrogen and ammonia which will
then be shipped to the island of Kirk in
Croatia from there hydrogen will travel
to serve Industrial off-takers in
southeast Europe and in parallel this
project will create local jobs and value
chains in
Brazil all of this shows more than ever
that Europe is not only a clean hydrogen
Pioneer but also a partner to build a
worldwide hydrogen
Market
with these public Investments we are
helping attract and mobilize massive
private Capital cooperation with the
private sector is my third and final
point this has always been the logic of
the European green deal we provide clear
rules and incentives so that you
inventors and investors can push forward
the clean
transition with you the industry in the
driving seat and this is why we have
just launched a series of clean
transition dialogues with each
industrial
ecosystem and it was only natural to
dedicate the first clean transition
dialogue to the hydrogen
industry last month we sat down with
many of you to plan the next phase for
the European hydrogen sector and now we
have to follow up on our conversation
and we will do just that by the end of
the year we will assess how member
states plan to implement their National
hydrogen commitments to provide you with
a clear road map towards 2030 in each
member
State we will also make it simpler to
access public
financing by creating a One-Stop shop
under the European hydrogen Bank to
guide hydrogen project promoters on EU
funding in our dialogue we also
discussed how to support producers and
consumers to better find each
other linking the demand and supply of
clean
hydrogen we will do this by creating a
public platform where consumers can
indicate their demand and producers can
find their off
takers these are just three examples
that show how we're moving to the next
phase from dialogue with in Industry to
the actual creation of Europe's hydrogen
Market setting it on the fast
track that is exactly the core business
of the European hydrogen week it is a
place where governments meet industry
companies meet
customers and ideas meet
investors it is a place where Vision
becomes
reality and this is the destiny of the
clean hydrogen
economy I wish you all a very successful
European hydrogen
week you really saw the commitment of
the president of the European commission
to really work for hydrogen she said it
comes only naturally to start the clean
energy the clean tech dialogues with
hydrogen but she really made sure that
she starts I I remember very well